this had all the Pomp and Circumstance
of a presidential inauguration the big
red carpet walk up their AIDS lined up
on either side two men bent on
restructuring the world order and
strengthening their ties
foreign
Putin especially this visit matters he
wants to project an image of grandeur of
one great power with another never mind
sanctions or war crimes indictments and
he needs China's support politically and
crucially economically
as for Ukraine he suggested it was the
West's time being prospects for peace
with a special mention for plans
outlined this week by the UK to supply
Kiev with shells containing depleted
uranium
[Applause]
and ideally
companion
these meetings Russia's key man on
Military technical cooperation and the
defense minister but nothing concrete on
NATO concerns that China might lend
Military Support to we haven't seen any
proof that China is delivering little
weapons to Russia but we have seen some
signs that this has been a request from
Russia and that this is an issue that is
is
considered
in Beijing or by the Chinese authorities
during it he's certainly wasn't telling
economic Lifeline adding military aid to
the mix would hardly fit with President
xi's peacemaking credentials or with the
narrative that he shares with Russia
that it is the flow of Western weapons
that are fueling this conflict
sanctions have made Russia heavily
dependent on China energy flows are
going east at discounted prices and the
deal signed today suggests a lot of
other things will be too president XI
has little to lose and much to gain by
sticking with the status quo
Diana McNeese Sky News Moscow